DISCUSSION, WE CAN HAVE IT -- >>
I JUST WANTED TO SAY,
>> WELCOME TO HANNITY IT.
IT WAS A HUGE DAY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNING PHASE
ONE, A HISTORIC NEW TRADE DEAL
WITH CHINA. BENEFITING OUR
ECONOMY, JOBS, GDP, STRAIGHT ON
DOWN THE LINE.
FOR YEARS, DECADES CHINA HAS
TAKEN FULL ADVANTAGE OF THIS
COUNTRY FAR TOO LONG.
NO PRESIDENT HAS BEEN UP TO THE
CHALLENGE FOR FREER AND FAIRER
TRADE DEALS WITH CHINA AND
OTHERS.
THE GREAT NEWS IS THIS WILL
BRING HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN REVENUE TO AMERICAN
FARMERS, AMERICAN MANUFACTURES,
SERVICE INDUSTRIES AND MUCH
MORE.
OVER TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT'S JUST THE NEXT TWO YEARS
ALONE.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER MAJOR
PROMISE MADE.
PROMISE KEPT BY THE PRESIDENT,
THAT YOU WILL NEVER HEAR FROM
THE MEDIA MOB.
WE HAVE ALL OF THE DETAILS.
VERY BIG DAY TO DAY FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS.
WE WILL TELL BUT IT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS BUSY MAKING
DEALS TO MAKE THE LIVES BETTER
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMS
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMW
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMH
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMA
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMO
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMH
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMR
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMP
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EML
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EMC
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.PUGH EML
STUNT.
AFTER STALLING FOR WEEKS WE HAVE
A DERANGED SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI.
FINALLY ANNOUNCING HER HAND
SELECTED IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS.
YOU WOULD THINK SHE THINKS SHE
IS PRESIDENT.
SHE DID THIS SO PRAYER FULLY THE
ARTICLES OF THE SENATE WILL.
>> THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT DAY
FOR US.
AS YOU KNOW ON REFERENCE, TEMPLE
MARKERS THAT OUR FOUNDERS AND
POETS AND OTHERS HAVE USED
OVERTIME TO PLACE US IN TIME, TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF TIME
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
TIME.
HOW WE USE IT, HOW WE, HOW WE
MARK IT, AND TODAY IS A
IMPORTANT DAY.
TODAY IS THE DAY THAT WE NAMED
THE MANAGERS TO GO TO THE FLOOR
TO PASS THE RESOLUTION TO
TRANSMIT THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT TO THE SENATE.
>> THEN THE SIGNING WAS WORST.
AFTER THAT PELOSI TRANSMITTED
THE ARTICLES TO THE SENATE.
NOT BEFORE AGREEFUL, PRAYERFUL
CEREMONY WHERE PELOSI SIGNED OFF
ON THE PROCESS.
SHE USED AN A SORTMENT OF PENS.
DISTRIBUTING TO HER SMILING
COLLEAGUES.
TAKE THIS TO GIVE TO YOUR
CHILDREN.
PRAYERFUL, URGENTLY PASSED
BEFORE CHRISTMAS, THEN GO ON
VACATION, AND THEN HOLD IT
LONGER THIS.
IS ALL PART OF HER SOLEMN DUTY,
REMEMBER.
AS FOR THE IMPEACHMENT MANAGER
SELECTED.
TPRAEUFPBGLY A GIFT TO DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY REPRESENT THE DEMOCRATIC
LAST CHANCE.
THE WHOLE PROS HAS BEEN A SHIFT
SHAM SHOW AND A POLITICAL HIT
JOB FROM BEGINNING UNTIL END.
PELOSI WANTS TO KEEP THE JOB AS
SPEAKER, SELECTED A GROUP OF THE
MOST HYPER PARTISAN CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, TRUMP HATERS.
SHE HIRED THE MOST EXTREME TRUMP
HATING DEMOCRATS.
AS THE FEDERALS POEBTED OUT ALL
OF THE MANAGERS ARE DOSSIER
TRUTHERS.
LET'S GET TO KNOW THE TRUMP
HATING CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
LEADING THE WAY, A DIFFERENT FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
ADAM SCHIFF.
THE PHI THAT NEEDS TO BE CALLED
AS A WITNESS IN THE CASE.
LIKE HIS FELLOW MANAGERS SPENT
YEARS SPREADING THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX.
LIED FOR THREE STRAIGHT YEARS
NONSTOP.
SAID THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF THE TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
HE LIED DAILY YOU THIS HIS
TEETH.
MORE RECENTLY FABRICATING THE
TRANSCRIPT WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
YES THE CONGENITAL LIAR'S OFF
THE IS IN TALKS WITH THE WHISTLE
BLOWER BEFORE THEY FILED A
COMPLAINT.
ANOTHER LIE, TRY TO COVER UP
THAT CONTACT.
LYING P IT ON NATIONAL TV.
AFTER HE WAS CAUGHT IN THE BOLD
FACED LIE HE REFUSED TO LET THE
WHISTLE BLOWER TO TESTIFY.
SCHIFF IS A WITNESS IN HIS OWN
SHIFT SHOW.
HE SHOULD BE CALLED AS A WITNESS
IN THE CASE.
YOU SAY CONFLICT OF INTERESTING.
OH, ONE OF THE MOST DISLIKED
PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
INTERESTINGLY HE'S THE ONLY GUY
ON TAPE THAT YOU CAN HEAR IN HIS
OWN WORDS CONSPIRING WITH
SOMEONE HE BELIEVES TO BE A
RUSSIAN TO GET DIRT ON DONALD
TRUMP TO USE IT IN A CAMPAIGN.
OH I THOUGHT THAT WAS, WHAT IS
THE NATURE OF THE COMPROMISING.
COMPROMISING MATERIALS.
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE, NAKED PICTURES OF
TRUMP.
NAKED PICTURES.
DOES VLADIMIR KNOW?
THAT'S ALL ON TAPE WITH HIM.
YESTERDAY LAST DITCH EFFORT,
HAIL MARY SMEAR JOB HE ATTACHED
NEW ARTICLES INCLUDING SO CALLED
EVIDENCE FROM A FORMER DUEL
YANNI CON TACK.
ON CONSPIRACY TV THE GUY IS
FACING CHARGES FROM THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MESS WITH
THOSE PEOPLE.
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATIONS AND
ALL SORTS OF STUFF.
HE GOES TO THE CONSPIRACY
CHANNEL MEDIA.
KEEP IN MIND WHEN PEOPLE LIKE
HIM TRY TO STAY OUT OF JAIL,
THINK ABOUT THIS, HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE WE HEARD FROM THE LIBERALS
YOU CAN'T WATER BOARD, THEY WILL
LIE TO MAKE IT END.
WELL PEOPLE TRY TO STAY OUT OF
JAIL, IN MY HUMBLE OPINION, THEY
WILL SAY ANYTHING.
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO SMEAR TRUMP
YOU'RE WELCOMED.
THOSE INDICTED WANTED LESS JAIL
SENTENCES ARE WELCOMED ON NBC.
ANOTHER FIRST RATE HYPOCRITE
FROM NEW YORK, DAYS AFTER THE
ELECTION NADLER ISSUED A
PROCLAMATION.
WE CAN'T WAIT FOUR YEARS TO VOTE
MR. TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE.
HE WANTED TO IMPEACH TRUMP THE
DAY HE WAS ELECTED.
ALSO PROMISING HE WOULD IMPEACH
TRUMP.
WHAT FOR, WE WILL MAKE IT UP AS
WE GO.
HE DIDN'T WANT THE KEN STARR
REPORT, HE HAD CRIMES COMMITTED
BY BILL CLINTON.
HE DIDN'T WANT THAT PUBLIC.
HE WANTED THE ROBERT MUELLER
REPORT NOT TO BE MANDATED GO
OUT.
LESSER KNOWN MANAGERS APPOINTED
BY PELOSI.
THEY HAVE CONGRESS WOMEN AND MEN
SUPPORTING IMPEACHMENT.
AFTER THE MUELLER REPORT THE
FOURTH INVESTIGATION FOUND ZERO
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OF CONSPIRACY.
FELLOW MANAGER SUPPORTING AL
GREEN'S BASELESS IMPEACHMENT.
MEANWHILE ANOTHER MANAGER
CONGRESS WOMAN AND ARM CHAIR
PSYCHOLOGIST, SAYING THE
PRESIDENT WAS AN OLD PERSON
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL DECLINE.
I GUESS SHE WASN'T TALKING
ABOUT JOE BIDEN WHO INVITES
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE.
HERE IS HAKIM JEFFREYS, EVERY
RACE IS IN AMERICA VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THOSE ARE THE DERANGED IDIOTS
REPRESENTING IMPEACHMENT.
HOW FITTING.
WITH THIS IS PELOSI THAT
DESPERATE TO CLING TO THE
SPEAKER SHIP.
SHE'S NOT REALLY SPEAKER
ANYMORE.
THAT WOULD BE CORTEZ.
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY.
AFTER CLAIMING URGENCY, HAVE TO
GET THIS DONE AND THEN GO ON
VACATION.
SO URGENT WE HAVE TO GO ON
THEN STALLING FOR WEEKS AFTER
THAT JONATHAN TURLEY WROTE,
"PELOSI" DESTROYED HER OWN CASE
FOR IMPEACHMENT ."
ONCE IN A WHILE CNN GETS
SOMETHING RIGHT.
THEY CLAIM PELOSI GAMBLED AND
SHE LOST.
NOW THE TRIAL WILL START NEXT
WEEK.
YES THOSE PEOPLE HAVE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THEIR
WEAK, PARTISAN, UNFOUNDED
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT AND BE
HELPING THE PRESIDENT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THROUGH
THIS, THE SCHIFF-SHAM SHOW.
NOW THE SENATE THEY'RE HELL BENT
ON HELPING THE PROCESS WHEN THEY
SHOULD END IT.
THEY WANT TO WASTE TIME AND CALL
WITNESSES.
I DO HAVE GOOD NEWS TO REPORT.
SENATOR LIKE TED CRUZ IN TEXAS
NOTING A PRETTY INTERESTING IDEA
AND DEAL.
WITNESS RECIPROCITY.
DEMOCRATS CAN CALL WITNESSES,
ALL WHO LIKELY WON'T TESTIFY
BECAUSE IT IS THE PRESIDENT THAT
HAS THE RIGHT TO USE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE LIKE EVERY PRESIDENT
BEFORE HIM.
HE SAID HE WOULD USE IT LIKE
OBAMA AND CLINTON, LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE.
THEN REPUBLICANS CAN CALL WHO
THEY WANT.
I SAY CALL QUI QUO PRO JOE, CALL
EXPERIENCED HUNTER, THE REAL
UKRAINIAN SCANDAL.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS UNLESS YOU FIRE
THE PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING
ZERO EXPERIENCE SON OF MINE PAID
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IF YOU FIRE HIM WE WILL GIVE YOU
THE BILLION.
THAT WAS THE GREAT THING ABOUT
THE NEW EVIDENCE PRESENTED
YESTERDAY.
JOE BIDEN AND HUNTER TOTALLY
INNOCENT.
THE PROSECUTOR IS CORRUPT.
WHY IS HE CORRUPT?
HE SAW A COMPANY PAYING THERE NO
OTHER COMPANY WOULD PAY FOR ZERO
EXPERIENCE.
THE NON WHISTLELIER HERE, SAY
WHISTLELIER.
LET'S BRING IN THE HERE IS A
WHISTLE BLOWER.
PEOPLE SEEM TO FORGET THE
PRESIDENT HAS PAINFULLY EXECUTED
THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
THAT MEANS HE HAS A DUTY.
IT MEANS HE HAS AN OBLIGATION.
HE MADE A PLEDGE TO INVESTIGATE
POTENTIAL CRIMES.
WHAT JOE BIDEN ADMITS TO IS A
CRIME IN MY BOOK WHERE I COME
FROM.
HUNTER RECEIVED THE MILLIONS
FROM THE UKRAINIAN GIANT AND AS
A FATHER OVERSAW THE POLICY IN
UKRAINE.
NOW WHAT BUSINESS.
THIS IS NOT A TOUGH JEOPARDY
QUESTION.
WHAT BUSINESS WOULD EVER PAY
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO SOMEBODY WITH ZERO
EXPERIENCE?
I CAN'T THINK OF ONE EXCEPT THE
COMPANY THAT MAY BE TRYING TO
BUY INFLUENCE.
BRING IN QUI QUO PRO JOE AND
ZERO EXPERIENCED HUBTER.
BRING THE FAX TO THE TABLE, FULL